IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN HERE
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
LIMITED NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN. A SIX
FOOT DISTANCE. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TEST I AM A
BILL PLEASE RAISE. I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME IT'S IF
YOU'RE IN THIS ROOM. I WHAT
ELSE GLASS ASK THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE WHEN YOU
COME UP TO THE FRONT. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU
ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITOL
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON. AT A TIME.
IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING. USE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS AND IN OTHER LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. THOSE
LOCATIONS ARE LISTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOMS
AND ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS WE
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE- THROUGH
WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY
ON A BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER
TO THIS HEARING IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN. PLEASE DO SO
ON THE IS PLEASE DO STE PLEASE
PLAN TO DO SO. AS THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL YOUR ARE YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN Q. BASE ON. SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE THE BILL. IF YOUR
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE- THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SATISFACTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOUR MAIN
WITNESS TEST PROVIDING
TESTIMONY OF FOUR AGAINST OF
THE- YOUR MAIN ON A LIVE LINE
AND WILL NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF.
UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON TO SPEAK.
IF YOU'RE HAVING A PROBLEM WITH
A MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2087 AND MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE. TO ASSIST YOU. I ALSO
WANT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY-
THROUGH. THROUGH THE POSITION
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE SO IF
YOU HAVE AN OPINION. HE CAN'T
SPEAK ON THE PHONE YOU DON'T
WANT TO SPEAK ON THE PHONE. GO
TO THE COMMITTEES WEBSITE THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SUBMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY THERE THAT'S AN EASY
WAY TO DO IT. THANK YOU FOR. BE
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL. OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SITUATION WE OFFICE. AND
I JUST WANNA SAY WERE HAVE TWO
MAIN WITNESSES TO AND TO LOVE
TO MINUTES EACH TO- TO IN
SUPPORT AND THEN TO IN
OPPOSITION. TO MR OF THE OTHERS
THAT ARE MAYBE ON THE PHONE IS
OR OR WHEREVER. YOU ONLY GET A
COME UP IN THE WHAT YOU GOTTA
DO IS SAY YOU'RE- YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION OF YOUR WITH AN
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. ONLY AGAIN THE TWO
MAIN WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH. AND THEN- IF YOU WANT TO
JUST PLAN WITH YOUR NAME AND-
IF YOU HAVE A IF YOU'RE WITHIN
ORGANIZATION OR SOMETHING YOU
MAY DO SO WITH. LET'S LET'S
MOVED TO. WE DO ONE OF THE
CONSENT. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A-
TO MOVE. SINCE OF PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I LIKE HIM TO S.
EIGHT THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
PROBE AND FILING THREE A FOUR
AT THE MOTION IS SHE PASSED
PROBE O'DONNELL. I'VE HIGHLY
VALLEY. SORRY THAT WITH
O'DONNELL I AYE AYE. ALL RIGHT
MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I WEBER HI.
I HAVE SIX FOUR. SIX SO THAT IS
OUT THE KILL ARE NOW WE HAVE
THIS ROOF WAS BILL IT IS. FOR
ON THE BOTTOM ONE WORD I'M FOR
MY FOR. IF YOU WANT YOUR BILL
HEARD. YEAH.
YEAH WE WAIT FOR
YOU VERY OTHER THAN ENERGY
RIGHT NOW AND IT'S. AROUND
RIGHT WE ARE READY TO GO A
CENTER RUBIO YOU MAY PERCEIVE
ALREADY. HANK YOU. WELL MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COME IN SPEAKER
TODAY I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE SHE'S
DONE A LOT OF WORK ON THIS BILL
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS DESCRIBED ON PAGE
ELEVEN AND TWELVE OF THE
ANALYSIS MY SUPPORT WITNESS
WILL BE DOCTOR MAYBE MILLER
PROFESSOR IN THE SCHOOL OF.
EDUCATION AT CSU CHICO AND
RIGHT JAIL THE SORROW SENIOR
COUNSEL PUBLIC ADVOCATES BOTH
OF WHOM ARE FORMER EDUCATORS
DOCTOR MILLER WILL BE
PARTICIPATING THROUGH TELEPHONE
AND IT MESSES WITH OUR WILL BE
PARTICIPATING VIA THE OAK OP
CONFERENCE. WELL FIRST. I WANT
TO START WITH THREE REALLY
IMPORTANT MISCONCEPTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN OUT THERE ARE NUMBER
ONE ON THIS BILL AND THAT'S
OVERSIGHT THE BILL REQUIRES THE
CITY TO REPORTS SPECIFIED
INFORMATION ON THE ASSESSMENT
AND IT'S PROGRESS I ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVE THERE HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE HAVE TO
HOLD THE COMMISSION
ACCOUNTABLE. BUT TO UPDATE THE
T. P. A.'S THE TPS WILL MERIT
THE SAME RIGOR AND VALUE AS THE
CURRENT ASSESSMENT THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE UPDATES TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
MISCONCEPTION OF WHOLE LANGUAGE
WHICH I'VE HEARD OFTEN THIS
BILL DOES NOT DIRECT THE
TEACHING OF WHOLE LANGUAGE.
THIS IS MISLEADING THE BILL IS
SPECIFICALLY. IT SPECIFICALLY
INCORPORATES FOUNDATIONAL
READING SKILLS AND LITERACY
SKILLS TO THE T. P. EIGHT
THIRTY PAYS WILL BE UPDATED TO
INCLUDE THE SCIENCE OF READING.
IN A MANNER ONLINE TO THE
CURRENT EMAIL A AN EMAIL THE
FRAMEWORK THAT T. PIECE. ON
STUDENT SUCCESS. I AM THE PROUD
FATHER OF THIS BILL BECAUSE OF
MY PERSONAL SEVENTEEN YEARS IN
THE CLASSROOM. NOT ONLY AS AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER BUT
AS AN ADMINISTRATOR AND MASTER
TEACHER WHO MENTORED MANY
TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM. AND
SO MY NUMBER ONE GOAL IS TO
HAVE TEACHERS THAT ARE
QUALIFIED. THEY'RE EFFECTIVE
AND READY TO TEACH ON DAY ONE
WE MUST DO BETTER BY OUR
STUDENTS SB SIX ONE FOUR IS
NEEDED BECAUSE THE CURRENT RICA
IS FILLING OUR STUDENTS.
PROSPECT PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS
AND HAS DONE NOTHING TO PREPARE
THOSE ALREADY IN THE CLASSROOM.
I ACTUALLY TOOK THE RVCA TEST
MANY YEARS AFTER I WAS ALREADY
IN THE CLASSROOM IT DIDN'T MAKE
ME A BETTER TEACHER. I TAKE THE
TOUGH I PASSED IT. BY I WAS IN
BETTER PREPARED. IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION ADOPTED AN U. E. L.
A. LD FREE MARKET THAT REFLECTS
AN INTEGRATED APPROACH TO
LITERACY DEVELOPMENT. THIS
ASSESSMENT ADOPTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY SIX IS NOT ALIGNED TO
THE CURRENT K. TWELVE LA GUILTY
FRAMEWORK. OVER ITS TWENTY FOUR
YEARSTENURE RECALL HAS NOT
BEEN SHOWN TO PROTECT
EFFECTIVENESS IN THE CLASSROOM
IN FACT. MANY OF MY TEACHERS ON
THAT I MEANT. I HAD A ROUGH.
TIME AND AGAIN BEING THEIR
MENTOR I NEVER SAW THEM BE MORE
EFFECTIVE BECAUSE OF THAT TEST.
ADDITIONALLY IN A RECENT SURVEY
BY LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE.
80% OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
REPORTING HAVING TEACHER
CHARGES MEANWHILE THERE HAS
BEEN A 30% DROP IN ENROLLMENT
IN TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS
OVER THE LAST DECADE. I WANT TO
BE CLEAR. THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT MAKING IT EASIER FOR
TEACHERS. TO PASS IT IS ABOUT
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION AND HAVING TEACHERS
BETTER PREPARE ON DAY ONE. AND
ALSO BRINGING DIVERSITY TO THE
CLASSROOM BY ALLOWING TEACHER
CANDIDATES TO FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
TEACHERS OF COLOR AND
CANDIDATES THEY LEARN BETTER BY
ACTUALLY TEACHING IN A
CLASSROOM SETTING. THEY NEED TO
BE CHALLENGED BY REAL CLASS
SITUATIONS AND ALLOW THEM TO
BRING THEIR LIFE EXPERIENCE TO
THE TABLE. THIS BILL REQUIRES
ALL APPROVED TPS TO ACT A SAYS
CANDIDATES FROM MULTIPLE
SUBJECT AND EDUCATION
SPECIALIST. FOR COMPETENCE IN
INSTRUCTION IN LITERACY
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
FOUNDATIONAL READING SKILLS A
LINE TO THE CDC'S CURRENT
TEACHING PERFORMANCE
EXPECTATIONS. THIRTY PAYS OR
THE NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED GOLD
STANDARD. IT IS THE ONLY
ASSESSMENT THAT HAS BEEN SHOWN
TO SIGNIFICANTLY PREDICT
TEACHER EFFECTIVENESS AND IN
TEACHING READING. FURTHERMORE
AMENDMENTS WERE REQUIRE THAT
THE RECALL REMAIN IN PLACE
UNTIL JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND TO THE CDC HAS UPDATED
THEIR TEEPEES. LASTLY I ALSO
WANT TO BE CLEAR THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE CTC TO REPORT
INFORMATION JUST LIKE THREE
THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE THAT'S
WHERE I WANT IT THE ABILITY TO
BE. AND I HAVE QUESTIONS BUT
SOME MEMBERS OF THIS DíAS AND
I'M CONSIDERING MAKING IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE- MORE- UPDATING
THEM MORE OFTEN THAN THAN THE
REQUIREDON ON THE BILL SO
AGAIN I ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE IN
THE AND BETTER UP TEACHERS
BETTER PREPARE TEACHERS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MAKING SURE
THAT THERE ARE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS SO WE AS
LEGISLATURE HERE CAN LOOK BACK
AND KEEP HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE DOING
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO. I'M I
WILL DEFER NOW TO MY- MY
WITNESSES THANK YOU. THE FIRST
I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ME ME MILLER FROM CSU CHICO
WILD CAT. I BELIEVE MANY IS ON
THE PHONE. THANK YOU CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
DOCTOR MEANING MILLER A
PROFESSOR AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CHICO FOR TWENTY
YEARS I HAVE PREPARED
ELEMENTARY TEACHERS OUR STATE
ACCREDITED PROGRAM IS RIGOROUS.
POTENTIAL CANDIDATES MUST
EXACTLY COMPLETE COURSEWORK
SATELLITE THE COMMISSION
SANDERS SB. SIX HUNDRED HOURS
OF SUPERVISED TEACHING AND MORE.
ABOUT THE RATIONS OF THEIR
CLASS TEACHER SKILLS. CANADA
MUST HAVE KITCHEN PERFORMANCE
AT THAT AND BY LITERATE IN MATH
AND- DOCKING THERE TEACH WITH
THE AND NARRATIVE AND SAID LET
THEIR WORK TO CARE SPENT FOR
VALUATION BY CALIBRATED ORDERS.
IN ADDITION TO ALL THAT THEY
MUST EACH PATH THEIR RICA.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF OUR BEST
AND BRIGHTEST A LETTER THE
TEACHERS WHO HAVE MET AND
EXCEEDED ALL OF THE STRINGENT
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN BLOCKED
FOR THE. TEACHING PROFESSION BY
THE RECAP. EVERY WHAT INTO A
WAYS FOR IT HAS NOT BEEN SHOWN
TO HAVE PREDICT VALIDITY. WE DO
KNOW THAT A TEACHER WHO PASSED
WITH THE RECAP AS A BETTER
TEACHER THAN SOMEONE WHO DOES
NOT HAPPEN. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE ESPECIALLY WANT
OTHER ASSESSMENT LIKE FUTURE
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS HAVE
BEEN SHOWN TO PREDICT TEACHER
EFFECTIVENESS. SECOND TICKET
DOES NOT ALIGNED WITH CURRENT
HEY THE DOCTOR'S STANDARDS ARE
FRAMEWORK. THE CURRENT ID
DOCUMENTS RETAIN THE ESSENTIAL
COMPONENTS OF READING
INSTRUCTION INCLUDING
FOUNDATIONAL READING BUT THEY
ALSO INCLUDE A MUCH STRONGER
EMPHASIS ON LANGUAGE
ACQUISITION FROM BOTH NATIVE
AND NON NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKERS.
BECAUSE OF A LINE OUT OF DATE
STANDARD THE RETEST CANADA ON
SOME ESSENTIAL KNOWLEDGE NOT.
UP TO DATE HAD A GUY NEEDED TO
TEACH CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN. SB
SIX FOURTEEN REMOVES THE RVCA
AND INSTEAD ENSURED BUT THE
ABILITY TO TEACH FOUNDATIONAL
RADIO ACOSTA THROUGH STATE
APPROVED TEACHER PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENT THAT ARE BASED ON
CURRENT STANDARDS. AND I VOTE
ON THE X. FOURTEEN WILL ENSURE
THAT NEW TEACHER TO ENTER
CALIFORNIA'S CLASSROOM.
DEMONSTRATED BUT THEY ARE OPEN
TO TEACH THEIR STUDENTS HOW TO
READ THANK YOU. GREAT YOU WILL
NOW HEAR FOR A CASH FIREMAN.
I'M SORRY I APOLOGIZE MIX THAT
UP OF REGALE MASSARO- MISSILE I
BELIEVE- FROM PUBLIC ADVOCATES
IN THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM REBEL
AND IF I GET FIVE. YOUR NAME I
APOLOGIZE YOU MAY CORRECT ME.
MY NAME IS THE SORROW AND A
FORMER TEACHER AND A SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL A PUBLIC
ADVOCATES. FOR NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR
A ROBUST WELL PREPARE AND
DIVERSE TEACHER WORK FORCE IS
STRONG SUPPORT SB SIX FOURTEEN
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. TO
ELIMINATE THE RVCA AND INSTEAD
ADDS FOUNDATIONAL READING TO
THE T. P. A. THE SCORE THAT
ALIGNS WITH OUR VISION AND DOES
NOT WATER DOWN OUR STANDARDS
FOR TEACHER QUALITY. CALIFORNIA
FACES A DIRE TEACHERS.
EVERYTHING THE BENEFIT OF A
NINE HUNDRED DOLLAR INVESTMENT
THIS YEAR THAT WORKS CONTRACT
WITH MY 10% BECAUSE OF CO. YOU
ARE WELL AWARE MOST VULNERABLE
IT IS JUST FORTUNATE BLANK OUR
SERVER. IF EDGE. THREE NOT HELP
STUDENTS. TEACHERS FOR OVER
TWENTY FOUR YEARS AT NEVER BEEN
SHOWN TO BE. A CLASSROOM
PERFORM. PRE RECAST 88% OF
STATES HAVE HIGHER READING
SCORES CALIFORNIA AND AFTER TEN
YEARS OF 387% STILL
OUTPERFORMED US. THE M. REMAINS
CULTURALLY UNRESPONSIVE TO NEW
THINGS AND READING INSTRUCTION
SUCH AS MODIFICATIONS FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND STUDENTS
DISABILITIES INCLUDING.
DYSLEXIA WITH THE C. BEST A C.
SET THE REJECTS LOSE AT LEAST
40% OF THOSE WHO INITIALLY
INTENDS TO TEACH. THE FIRST
PASS RATE IS SIXTY FIVE PER.
AND MORE TROUBLING THAT FOR BY
AND LATINO X. CAN'T. CURRENT
RESEARCH QUESTIONS THE EFFICACY
AND BIASED OF STANDARDIZED
TESTING SUGGESTING THAT
PERFORMANCE IN MULTIPLE
MEASURES ASSESSMENTS MORE
ACCURATELY ASSESS KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILLS. THE TVA IS JUST SUCH AN
ASSESSMENT ITS RESULTS ARE
AGGREGATED AND REPORTED THE TP
A IS A IS FAR SUPERIOR TO THE
READ THAT AS A AS A VEHICLE TO.
TEST FOUNDATIONAL REDUCED.
ACCORDINGLY WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. BE SIX. FOURTEEN YEAH.
THANK YOU ARE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PUB WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S A
INSIDE THE BUILDING INSIDE THIS
ROOM RIGHT NOW THE WISHES TO
TEST. SUPPORT I'LL- SING OVER.
WISH TO JUST AGAIN ON THIS YOU
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY NOTHING MORE THAN
THAT- IS THERE ANYONE REMOTELY
JUST TO DO THAT. THOSE THAT
WERE TO GO TO THE PHONE. AND
MODERATOR CAN YOU HEAR ME. I
THANK AT. GREAT THANK YOU ARE
AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO NOW IS
RUNNING ON THE PHONES AND THEY
THE IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE ON
THOUGH IF YOU'RE GONNA TEST BY
THE PHONE REALLY. ALL YOU'RE
DOING IS AND WHETHER IT'S A
SESSION THE YOUR NAME THE ASIAN
AND- ON THE BILL USED ANY MORE
THAN THAT MODERATOR PLEASE CUT
OFF. BECAUSE WE I'M SURE MANY
ONLINE WE WILL AND EVERY. GET A
CHANCE TO HAVE THEIR- HEARD ON
THIS. SO WITH THAT THAT'S FOR
THOSE A- MODERATOR YOU MAY GO
TO FOLKS. IF YOU WERE TO. POR
PRESS ONE. TIME. AND FOR OVER I
THANK BY NINE BRAD. LINE ONE
NINE NINE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THEY'RE ABOUT TO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. CHILDREN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BROUGH FROM CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER IN. THE QUEUE LINE
SIXTY PLEASE CALL AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JEREMY PANEL AGAINST
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX ONE FOUR.
THANK YOU I WON SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS MARTHA THERE ARE
GOES BUT THE ADS AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIX
FOURTEEN AT AT THE AMENDMENTS
OF THE COMMITTEE. YOU'RE LYING
TO THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE COUNTRY CODE OUR CHILDREN
BUT PRETENDING THAT AND BE ABLE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
ORDER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAD ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A YES RECORD MY
PRESIDENT OF THE ET T. PAY
TWELVE COUNSEL FOR THE FTA ANTI
RIGHT AND SUPPORT OF THAT. SIX
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU I. WE DON'T
HAVE. I WANTED TO SEVEN YEAH OF.
MODERATOR IF THEY DON'T SPEAK
JUST PASS THEM UP. YOU'RE RIGHT
ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BY AS THE BILL GARCIA
ON BEHALF OF OUR OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS. YES
YOU'RE RIGHT VOTE ON SENATE
BILL SIX FOURTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TWO HUNDRED IN
TIME PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I
WANT I'M A READING TEACHER
ACADEMIC COACH WITH TWENTY FOUR
YEARS EXPERIENCE FROM THE- COLD
I URGE YEAH SO ON THE SIX POINT
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
SIX TWENTY FOUR HAD. HI THIS IS
THAT WHATEVER THE FACT THAT I'M
ON THE OF LOS ANGELES SCHOOL
DISTRICT ORDER SB. SIX
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU I'M ONE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MEGAN AND MEDIA AND I
AM AN INCOMING FIRST YEAR
TEACHER IN DAVIS CALIFORNIA AND
I'M THINKING OF ART SB SIX
PARKING. THANK YOU I'M TWO
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE NUMBER SURELY DOWN BEHALF
HEALTH RECORD ASIAN AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE TO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHUPACABRA THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE. JERRY
NARRON PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL TEACHER EDUCATION AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX FORTY. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
STRONG SUPPORT SB SIX FORTY.
THANK YOU A LINE WENT OUT TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
ANNETTE BROWN I'M A TWENTY FIVE
YEAR VETERAN TEACHER AND
READING SPECIALIST IN THE
HOPPER CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF
YOU'RE NOT CONNECTED I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
LANGUAGE TEACHER ASSOCIATION
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO ANY BARA. ARE THEY AND
CAL FIVE AT THE PORT SB SIX
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU I'M TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD ACTORS NO MY NAME MARTY
UPDATE YEAH I AM BARGAIN PARK
LA LA YEAH. I ALL WELL. WE
THANKS MARK IN THE CAR I MY
THANK YOU THANK YOU MOVE ON.
LINE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS JANET EVANS
HAVE BEEN EDUCATED. FOR THIRTY
TWO YEARS AND I SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF. THANK YOU I ONE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO. MY NAME IS ACTED
NORMAL DAY BAKER PRESIDENT OF
BORED WITH THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS AND I AM STILL OPPOSE
SB SIX FOURTEEN. PINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY BOB GRANT
THE. ARM COACH HERE THE STUDENT
CALIFORNIA KEEP AT THE H.
STATEWIDE THAT COULD TEAM. A
I'M IN SUPPORT. OF SB SIX FOUR.
THANK YOU I'M TO SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH BUT IF THE ODDS
GOOD ENOUGH FOR PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA LATINO SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FOURTEEN. THANK YOU TO
OUR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS THE READING
HENDERSON AND I AM A LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL TEACHER
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE THEY
CALL TEAM. THANKS SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS DIRECT MINSKY FROM THE
FACT THAT THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION IN
FONG STRONG SUPPORT SENATE BILL
SIX ONE FOUR THANK YOU. TRYING
TO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
NICK WRONGLY ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I AND EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE DELAY
IN THE SCOTT I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL.
TEACHER EDUCATION AND CAL THE
OTHER IN THE POOR OF. ALL. SIX
ONE FOUR. THE THANK YOU TO
ALIVE PLEASE AHEAD. HI MY NAME
MELISSA LITTLE GOVERNOR I AM
ARTIST THE TEACHER FOR YOU THE
AND I WITH AT LEAST ONE FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M EIGHTY
FOUR FOUR HAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALEXA LAWRENCE ANOTHER TEACHER
CANDIDATES AT THE STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I SUPPORT SB SIX
ONE FOUR. THANK YOU I'M TWO
EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE CALL I HAD.
HI MY NAME IS THERE ACTUALLY
JOHN I THANK YOU KICKING IN THE
EXTENDED THE STATE. AT THE UBER
AND I. FOR THANK YOU AND I HAVE
NO FOR THE LINE THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WHEN I GO TO THE OPPOSITION-
THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES HAVE
TWO MINUTES EACH- I WILL
INTRODUCE THE FIRST OPPOSITION
WITNESS AND IS KAREEM WEAVER.
FROM THE OAKLAND AND DOUBLE ACP
TESTIFY IN WV ARE.
TO
DREAMWEAVER OPEN AND DOUBLE ACP
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL EVEN WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS BECAUSE OF
THE IMPACT THIS WILL HAVE ON
STUDENTS WHO NEED READING
INSTRUCTION AWAIT THAT LIMITS
ADULT BIAS AND GIVE THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF KIDS WHAT
THEY NEED IT'S NOT REALLY JUST
ABOUT THE RICO IT'S WHAT THE
RISK IS ATTACHED TO THE SCIENCE
OF READING IT'S AND THEN THE
CONTENTS IS. THE IS ONLY ABOUT
1% CHOOSE THAT OPTION IT ONLY
HALF OF THOSE EVER PASSAGE SO
IF YOU WANT TAKE THE CAR BUT OF
MANDATE THE AMPLE TESTER FINE
AS LONG AS YOU DON'T OUTSOURCE
OVERSIGHT TO SOMEBODY ELSE OR
WATER DOWN THE CONTENTS. AND
ACCREDITATION CHECK ON
UNIVERSITIES EVERY SEVEN YEARS
IS THE OVERSIGHT AND TWEAKING
THE GUIDANCE FROM OVER TWENTY
PAGES DOWN FULL PARAGRAPH IN A
FEW BUZZ WORDS IS WATERING IT
DOWN SO JUST THINK ABOUT THIS
LIKE YOU THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
THE STATE POLICE TO THE BEACH.
ALL OF THE ROAD YEAH WE HAVE
DRIVERS AT SCHOOL BUT WE DON'T
ADVOCATE RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAINTAIN OVERSIGHT OVER LEVELS
OF ALLEGIANCE THE STATE MAKES
TAKE BOTH THE CAL WRITTEN AND
TEST ADAM. AND MAKE NO MISTAKE
ABOUT IT THIS WILL HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON KIDS
YOU CAN LOOK AFRICAN AMERICAN
TO KEEP SELECT FOR THE THEY
NEED TO TALK SYSTEM X. IN
DIRECT BECAUSE WITH THAT
WHETHER YOU IT RACISM WORN
EXPECT GAP OF BIASES INTO PLAY
LASTLY THERE'S A REASON WHY
PRCENT OF PEOPLE ARE. THAT ARE
IN PRISON FUNCTIONALLY
ILLITERATE WE ALL WANTED THE
SCHOOL TO PUT THE BUT THIS BILL
ALBANY FOREHAND BUT THE CON
SPECS THAT HOLDS THE DEPTH AND
CLEAR FINANCE OF READING WHICH
MAKE THE WORSE NOT BETTER DON'T
RUSH THIS THROUGH THE MIDDLE.
EVEN WITH THE IS STRONG PULSE.
THANK YOU. I'M GONNA GO. THE
FIREMEN CSU SPAIN LOOKS LIKE
THIS. IS ARE IN. HERE THIS BILL.
THE WAY. VERSUS BAY I DON'T
KNOW WHY THEY ARE THE. USING
THE SCIENCE OF READING A
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED
EXPLICIT SYSTEMATIC DIRECTS THE
QUITE CHILL AND MULTI SENSORY
APPROACH TO READING AND
LANGUAGE. TEACHING READING IS
COMPLEX THE LANGUAGE OF THIS
BILL PROPOSES A WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE VERSION OF THE
SCIENCE OF READING AND FRANKLY
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE. EIGHTY FOUR
WORLD RENOWNED EXPERTS IN
READING AND LITERACY STRONG
OPPOSE THIS BILL WITH THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND SAID
WHY. THERE HAS BEEN A
DELIBERATE CHIPPING AWAY
ELIMINATION OF MANDATED
LANGUAGE FOR READING
INSTRUCTION REQUIRED FOR
TEACHER PREPARATION THIS BILL
SIGNIFICANTLY. EXISTING
DEFINITION OF READING
INSTRUCTION WHICH IT. FIRST
PART. AND HOW. BOTH THE
PATIENTS BEYOND JUST THE RE CUT
AND TEST PREP WE CANNOT ANY IN
THE IN THIS WERE THE PART
LANGUAGE IS ALSO ADELINE WITH
THE LA FRAMEWORK OF READING OR
HOW TO GUIDELINES CDC ALREADY
ELIMINATED PROGRAM FOR READING
AND ABOUT INTO THE SEVEN
BECAUSE OF THE EGGS. AND A LOT
ON THE READ IT'S CONT BUT THE-
THIS BILL WOULD NOW LEAVE US
WITH A ONE PARAGRAPH OF EACH
READING. THAT'S ACCEPTABLE. WE
THE READING OF CONTENTS TO
WRITE OUR SO BY YOU TO THAT OUT
AND READING INSTRUCTION BACK.
TO A TIME WHERE FOR MORE STILL.
FINALLY YOU CAN READ THE A SET.
AND IF BUT THE WITH THE TEACHER
PERFORMING ASSESSMENT THE
MEASURE TO SEE THING. THE
WRITTEN TEST ASSESSES WHAT
TEACH ACROSS ENTIRE TO BE.
SPECTRUM OF IN LATE. AND THE
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT IS HOW
YOU. AND IT IS JUST A SNAP OF
READING IS STRUCK FOR WHAT.
GREAT LOVE OF STUDENTS. THAT
WHICH IS TO OPPOSE THE BILL AT
THE REMOTE. TESTIMONY STATION.
NO OKAY WITH THAT WILL GO TO
THE PHONE WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY NOTHING FURTHER
PLEASE ON THE PHONE MODERATE.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHAT A LINE THREE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT A
LINE NUMBER SO I MISSED THE
SUPPORT THAT'S ABOUT BUT THANK
YOU. CLICK HERE FOR NEXT ONE
FOUR. TWO SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF IT IF NO ONE COMES ON
THE LINE MODERATE YOU MAY PASS
THEM UP. YOUR ADDRESS THE ONE
CHECK OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PAGE JUST BE ONE MORE MOMENT
BUT FOR LINE BUT UP.
I WANT TO
GET A LOT JUST BE A FEW MORE
SECONDS HERE.
HERE AGAIN IS
THREE PATIENTS FOR A MOMENT.
OKAY OVERLOOKED BY ABOUT FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES DR DELETES
WILLIAMS TWENTY YEAR COSTA CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ
STILL MOM IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND SANTA BARBARA PUBLIC
SCHOOL. IN LOS ANGELES ACTUALLY
SCHOOLS STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE ONE NINETY FOUR GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS YOKO OCCURRED
LACKEY WITH THE CODING DYSLEXIC
CALIFORNIA I'M SUPPOSED TO SB
SIX ONE FOUR. THANK YOU RIDE
ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS THE MARROW GLEASON ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
DYSLEXIA ASSOCIATION LOS
ANGELES BRANCH STILL OPPOSED TO
SB SIX ONE FOUR. THANK YOU NINE
TWO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PUBLIC SCHOOL EMPLOYEE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SIX FOURTEEN. THANK
YOU I'M TO TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS NICK NICHOLS' BROTHER
OF THE DYSLEXIC STUDENT AND I'M
STILL STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB
SIX FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ONE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES LISA SHARPER WITH
CONTRA COSTA- ACCORDING TO LIKE
BE A MOM TO A- DYSLEXIC AT H.
FAN AND I AM VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. THANK YOU
I'M TO TWENTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND ALEXANDER NICHOLS
AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AT
AT THE AT SIX FOURTEEN. ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
TWO FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS BETH OR SOBS I'M A
PARENT OF A DYSLEXIC STUDENT LA
UNIFIED AND I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB SIX ONE FOUR.
THANK YOU I'M TO FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KATHY. ERIC BUT FILED AT CANYON
EIFFEL I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BELT. SIX FOUR. THANK YOU I AND
ONE SIXTY TWO. AT JANE LOG ON
THE HOPE OF LEARNING RIGHT
LAWCENTER I WAS AT THREE SIX
FOUR EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
I'M. TO FIFTEEN FIFTY FIVE. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER PARKER I'M A
LITERACY FACTORED IN TEACHER
FOR SFU AT THE IN NINE STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SIX FOURTEEN. YOU
I'M WANT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. PINE
TO THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS RENEE WEBSTER
HAWKINS UNDER REGIONAL LEADER
FOR THEIR GREATER SACRAMENTO
AREA CODE IN COMPLEX YEAH
CALIFORNIA GROUP AND I'M ALSO
ON THAT PARENT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE FOR THE SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED. OKAY COMMITTEE
AND I'M STILL REMAIN STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB SIX FOURTEEN.
EIGHT MY NAME IS DOCTOR BRAD
SNYDER PRINCIPLE AND MEMBER OF
THE INTERNATIONAL DYSLEXIA
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SIX FORTY. THANK YOU I'M
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MANY SELENA ON BUT IT I'M
A SCHOOL. AND I DON'T GET
BOGGED BUT FEEL SIX FOURTEEN IT
WILL BE ON THE. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE OF SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS VERONICA NOR I'M AND
EDUCATION LAW ATTORNEY FOR
STUDENTS AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO BE SIX ONE FOUR. THANK YOU I
WON SIXTY FOUR POLITICAL AD.
YES MY NAME IS DOCTOR TAP INTO
FELT THE FACTORED IN NARRATIVE
THAT FEAR IS THE MAN FELL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AT THE FUNDS
FOR. THANK YOU I IN ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS AMANDA FOCCART CHEN I MEAN
ESL TEACHER IF THE YOU AND THE
AND A PARENT OF A DYSLEXIC
CHILD AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AT
THE SIX ONE FOUR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BYE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TOBY MY THE CODING TO CAL STATE
DIRECTOR WE ARE STILL STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB SIX FOURTEEN
RUBIO AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M TO FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KAREN ROSENQUIST ON THE MOTHER
OF DYSLEXICS TIME THE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATOR IN THE NUMBER OF
DECODING CONSTRUCTION
CALIFORNIA AND I STILL STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SIXTY SIX FOURTEEN
EVEN WITH THE AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE TWENTY NINE THREE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTY
DENNIS TO CALIFORNIA. STUDENTS
WHO BOB YEAH AND ARE OPEN BY
LINK WILL AND AM STILL AT THE
SIX ONE FOUR THANK. THANK YOU
FINE TUNING EIGHT WE'VE AHEAD.
MY NAME IS DAN A MOTHER THAT.
THE FACT SON AND I'M STRONG
OPPOSE TO AT THE STATE ONCE.
THANK YOU I AM TO NINE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME'S TONY LUCCHINI ARE MY
DISABILITY ADVOCATE FOR
FAMILIES IN THE LA YOU WITH THE
AREA AND I HAVE A SON WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AND I AM.
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB SIX
FOURTEEN INCLUDING THE
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU I AM TO
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SHANNON LAWLER AND
I'M THE MOTHER OF THE
DESTRUCTIVE DAUGHTER A MEMBER
OF THE CODING DYSLEXIA
CALIFORNIA AND THE IDEA A AND
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB SIX
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU I'M ONE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
BATH LUCY OF EARLY THERE SHE
SPECIALIST AND I AM STILL
STRONGLY OPPOSED THE BILL SIX
ONE FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ABOUT ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE CALL
I HAD. MY NAME IS GLENDA
CARVALHO SAL AND THE PARENT OF
A DYSLEXIC LEARNER AND I'M
STILL OPPOSED TO ASK. FOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I AM THRILLED
THAT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS LONG ISSUE I'M SPEAKING
FOR TO BE. I'M PARENT OF
DISCONNECT SIGN I AND THEN.
ACTIVITY BUT IT OUR KILL YOU
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE PROJECT I'M
WORKING GROUP AND WE THE- I AM
THE CARD THE NEEDED TEAM TV
EIGHTY YEARS JOHN ADAMS
STRONGLY OF. TO EIGHT BE SIX
FOURTEEN AND I'LL MY FRIENDS
HERE TESTIFIED LONG. FALL MY
NAME IS A- AND I THIS LECTURE
THANK. IN ARE YOU STILL OPPOSE
TO HE- THANKS HE- THANK YOU
WHAT ALIVE ONE NINE THREE
PLEASE AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
CALLING I NEED AND LOTS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I AM STILL
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU LINE TO THIRTEEN
FISCAL HAD. HELLO JENNIFER
RENAULT SO AM WITH THE CODE
IT'S LIKE A CALIFORNIA NUMBER
AND THE ITA I HAVE A CHILD WITH
DYSLEXIA AND I AM STILL OPPOSE
SB. SIX FOURTEEN. THANK YOU THE
RIGHT TO NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I WON ALL THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS EDWIN
FAGAN AND I AM STILL OPPOSE SB
SIX FOURTEEN. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS TRACY BLOCK DIRECTLY ON
THE CO FOUNDER THE DYSLEXIA
TRAINING IN SECURING THE PARENT
OF A CHILD WITH DYSLEXIA NIGHT
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX FOURTEEN
AND MY CHILDREN ARE HERE AS
WELL. HI MY NAME IS SCOTT HERE.
I AM. A MEMBER FOR AND I FEEL
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AT THE SIX
FOURTEEN. I AM JOEY. ADDRESS
AND I AND I HAD DYSLEXIA AND
I'M AND I. I'M A SCHOOL AND I
OPPOSE. SB THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I AM TO TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS ROBERT
AND I'M ON THE CUTTING THIS
LECTURE CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND A PARENT OF A
DYSLEXIC NINE YEAR OLD DAUGHTER
WHO'S BILINGUAL AND I'M STILL
OPPOSED TO SB SIX FOURTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M SIXTY SIX PLEASE GLAD.
HI MY NAME IS KIMBERLY ANG LEE
AND THE PALO ALTO UIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT ELECTED PARENT
REPRESENTATIVES WITHOUT THE ONE
SEAT THREE AND I'M STILL
OPPOSED TO SB SIX WORKING WITH
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS FRAN WHETHER OF
FORMER TEACHER PARENT AND
GRANDPARENT HAVE DYSLEXIC
STUDENTS AND I AM STILL OPPOSED
TO SB. SIX FOURTEEN. THANK YOU
I'M TWO HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME OUR- MY DON'T DELAY
AND BADLY AND BEING THANKS FOR
BEING MY DAD HERE. HEY MY NAME
IS THAT AND I HAVE LIKE AND I
AM VERY. IT THREE EIGHT SIX
QUITE IN. THANK YOU I'M STAR
PLEASE CALL. THANK YOU ARE TO
PUT THESE GLAD. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH LAST WEEK AND I STILL
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SIX
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU I'M TO
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO OUT. HI MY
NAME IS LOWER TWENTY THREE
BURKE I AM A BIG THE BALLOT IN
A READING SPECIALIST WITH
THIRTY YEARS EXPERIENCE I AM
STILL OPPOSE SB SIX FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU NINE TO SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD OF. YES MY NAME
IS RATHER CALMLY ROBERTS AND
I'M CERTIFIED SPECIAL EDUCATION
ADVOCATE AND A DOG I HAVE A
DAUGHTER SELECT YEAH I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB. SIX ONE FOUR AND I
HAVE MY DAUGHTER ALSO. AYE
OPPOSED SB ONE FOR ROBERTSON.
THANK THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS MEGAN HOW CAN THEY ARE
WITH THE FAMILY FOR UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT COMMUNITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND THE PUTTING THE
BLACK YEAH I'M A PARENT AND AN
EDUCATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
AT THE ONE AT SIX FOURTEEN WITH
AMENDMENT THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU I'M TO FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THAT THE REAL PLAN I AM THE
PARENT OF AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHILD WITH DYSLEXIA AND I'M
STILL OPPOSED TO AT THE SIX ONE
FOUR. THANK YOU I WON SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
INDIVIDUAL NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
BRANCH- HIDING AA- LEARNING
SPECIALIST AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. ONE SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU RIGHT FORTY THREE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SHARE
HAND I'M A PDF OPHTHALMOLOGIST
I'VE WRITTEN THE POLICY
STATEMENT FOR THE ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS AND AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF OPHTHALMOLOGY AND READING
DISABILITY AND I AM STILL
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB. SIX ONE
FOUR. THANK YOU I AM EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS WENDY FIND BURKE I AM
THE MOTHER OF AN ADULT THAT
FLEX EXXON AND I AM STILL
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB. SIX ONE
FOUR. THANK YOU I'D ONE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SANDRA
THANK HAN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL AND READING
SPECIALISTS I AM STILL OPPOSE
AT THE SIX ONE FOUR. THANK YOU
I IN TWO OR THREE PLEASE. BY MY
ALONG WITH WHAT THE JOHN I'M AT
PATHOLOGIST AND READING
SPECIALIST RUN A SCHOOL FOR
KIDS WITH THE PLAN YEAH I AM
OPPOSED TO- SIX ONE FOUR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE TO EIGHTEEN
COULD GO I HAD. MY NAME IS GAIL
SPEND MORE REPRESENTING THE
INTERNET DYSLEXIA. THE LA
BRANCH WITH ALSO AHEAD OF A
SCHOOL FOR CHILDREN WITH
DYSLEXIA FOR MANY YEARS AND I'M
STILL OPPOSED SB SIX FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU I WON TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS A LEAD OF FISHER. GIVE ME
I'M NOT LIKE I NAY ADVOCATE THE
CHAIR FOR THE COMMUNITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
ALTHOUGH THE PARENT OF A
DAUGHTER WITH VISUAL PROCESSING
DISORDER I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB.
SIX ONE FOUR. THANK YOU RIGHT
TO FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS BETH EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR BUT I WILL OPPOSED AT
THE. SIX ONE FOUR. THANK YOU I
WON TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT WAS CLEAR PRESIDENT
AT BOYS STILL MISSING KEY
ELEMENTS OF READING SCIENCE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO SIX ONE FOUR.
THANK YOU I'M THREE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M WILLIAM.
PATTERSON A SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER AND READING TUTOR AND I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SENATE
BILL SIX ONE FOUR. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JUDITH DOWN. AND I'M A
MEMBER ID EIGHT ALONG WITH
BEING THE WIFE AND MOTHER OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE SELECT.
OUT THE LITERARY HAWKINS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX ONE FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WHAT MIGHT
ONE EIGHT THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME. IS
MARYLAND STORY I LOVE FOR AT
THE TO BRING. PRINCIPLE AND SHE
ADDED A COLLEGE AT THE NEEDS TO.
I STRONG OPPOSE SB. SIX ONE
FOUR. THANK YOU I'M TWO SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE CALL HAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS AMBER ROBINSON BERMAN
STIR I'M AFFILIATED WITH THE
CODING DYSLEXIA AND I'M A
PARENT OF THE DYSLEXIC SON AND
I STILL OPPOSE SB AT SIX ON
FOUR. IF YOUR MIND THREE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MELISSA LACK BUT ALL I WAS A
PROFESSOR AT POINT LOMA
NAZARENE UNIVERSITY FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR THE
FIND THE BREEDING AND FOR
DYSLEXIA I AM ALSO THE MOTHER
OF A SON WITH DYSLEXIA. I AM
STRONGLY STILL OPPOSED SB SIX
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIVE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE THIRTY THREE THIRTY
FOUR HAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
CARLA MALDONADO I IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION ADVOCATE A NUMBER. OF
I THE A AND A OF A WITH AND A
FELT STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. ONE
FOUR EVEN WITH AMENDMENT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WON TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
THAT THE COMING AND I AM A
PARENT OF TWO CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS FROM PLAN WITH
DYSLEXIA AND I STILL STRONGLY
OPPOSE SENATE BILL SIX FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU MIGHT ONE FIFTY SIX
THE SCHOOL HAD. HI MY NAME IS
NANCY WILEY AND I AM THE PARENT
OF TWO ADULT CHILDREN WITH
DYSLEXIA AND I OPPOSE- AT FEET.
SIX FOURTEEN. THANK YOU I'M TO
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JAMISON COMINGS AND
I HAVE A CHILD WITH DYSLEXIA
THE PLUG WITH THAT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SB SIX FOURTEEN WHAT
THE ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK
HEAVEN THREE GLAD. THE THREE
CAN YOU. I AM BEATRICE GUN I'M
A TAXPAYER AND I AM STILL
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SIX ONE
FOUR. THANK YOU BUT I. I'M GLAD.
ONE YEAH. FIVE TWENTY PLEASE GO
I HAD. HI THIS IS DIANE WALLACE
I'M A CAREER EDUCATOR FUTURE
THROUGH A WIDE PROJECT DIRECTOR
AND I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THE AMENDMENT AND THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE TRYING TO FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY
NAME IS MARLENE HAGOPIAN. I'M A
CURRICULUM SPECIALIST RETIRED.
THE CARD OF A DYSLEXIC ON I WAS
IN EFFECT BUT RIDER AND NOW I'M
A GRANDMOTHER WHO HAS HAD TO
TUTOR ALL CORPORATE GRAND
CHILDREN AND OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS IN READING BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE
INSTRUCTION THEY NEED IN THE
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL. AT THE
SIX ONE FOUR. THANK THE COURT
MODERATE MILAN PLEASE. YEAH I
HAVE THE RIGHT. BLIND TO IT AT.
FOR THE- RIGHT ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREW
SUTHERLAND AND I'M A PARENT AND
THE SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I CURRENTLY
SERVE ON THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN COMMITTEE
I'M ALSO A VOLUNTEER ORGANIZER
FOR THE CA THE LEADERSHIP
COLLABORATIVE THE COALITION FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
LEARNING DISABILITIES
ASSOCIATION. I AM STILL OPPOSED
TO THE BILL SB SIX FOURTEEN
EVEN WITH THE AMENDMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NINE ONE NINETY
ONE PLEASE GO I HAD. YES MY
NAME IS VICKY ALTER WITH I AM A
TRAINER AND COACH OF SYDNEY
ELEMENTARY MIDDLE SCHOOL IN
SPECIAL ED TEACHERS IN THE AREA
LETTER C. AND I AM STRONG
OPPOSED TO SB. SIX ONE FOUR.
THANK YOU I AM TO FIFTY TWO
PLEASE SO I HAD. MY NAME IS
KERRY ABRAMS I'M A SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST AND PARENT
OF A CHILD WITH DYSLEXIA AND I
AM STILL OPPOSED TO SB SIX
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU DIVIDE BY
NOW EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE TWO FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS HI S. ACADIAN I'M A
READING TUTOR AND A CO FOUNDER
OF THE DYSLEXIA PARENT SUPPORT
GROUP OF SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY- I
REPRESENT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
PARENTS WHO ALL OPPOSE SB SIX
ONE FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YOU TO PLEASE SPELL HAD. I LIKE
TO LOOK AT IT IN A TRONG WE
OPPOSE SB SIX FOURTEEN. THANK
YOU I AM THREE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE CALL HAD. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA ALBERS SALVATOR I AM
A PARENT IN THE CUPERTINO UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I'M ALSO
PART OF THE IDEA A NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I HAVE A SON
WITH DYSLEXIA AND I APPROVED OF
SB SIX FOURTEEN EVEN WITH THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BYE AND THREE FORTY SIX
PLEASE CALL I HAD. HI MY NAME
IS MARY LOPEZ CRYING AND THE
TEACHER BURBANK HEIGHTS ONE
HAVE TAUGHT THE STUDENTS FOR
THIRTY ONE YEARS. I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB SIX FOURTEEN EVEN
WITH AMENDMENT. THANK YOU I AM
ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO I HAD.
STE HELLO MY NAME IS BACK TO
NORMAL BAKER THEN THE VOICES
BUT AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
AND THAT THE- DO NOT SUPPORT
AIR THE- SIX ONE FOUR. EVEN
WITH THE MEN. THANK YOU I AM
THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE SHANNON THOMPSON I
AM A SPECIAL EDUCATION ADVOCATE
REPRESENTING EDUCATE ADVOCATE
WE OPPOSE SB SIX ONE FOUR AS
AMENDED AND IT AND IN ITS
ORIGINAL FORM. THANK YOU RIGHT
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JOHN MULTI I'M AN
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AT A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR PARENT CHILD
ADVOCACY WE REMAIN STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB SIX FOURTEEN EVEN
WITH THE AMENDMENT. THANK.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE GOOD
HONOR AND I AM OPTIMISTIC IN
THEIR LEARN LEGALLY WE CAN READ
TO READ EASILY AT AGE FOUR AND
WITH GOOD INSTRUCTIONS NINE
AFFILIATED WITH THE ABILITY I.
OPPOSITE THAT FOR. THANK YOU I
AM TO ZERO FOUR CALL AHEAD. I
AM THREE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
I HAD. HI MY NAME CAN YOU HEAR
ME HI MY NAME IS RICK A I'M A
PSYCHOLOGIST I AM STRONGLY. THE
F. SIX FOUR WITH THEM. THANK
YOU I NEED THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SET
RECALL YAMAMOTO- I'M NOT ONE OF
THE COURTS HERE FOR HELLO I WAS
TOLD COMMUNITY OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND ALSO THE PAIR OF
A PARENT OF THE JURY PAYMENT
CHILD. A LOT OF THE UNIFIED
DISTRICT I'M STILL A STRONGLY
OPPOSES IF SIX FOURTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TWO ZERO
PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
JUDY RISING I AM A READING
CONSULTANT AS WELL AS A
PRIVATE- PUBLIC SCHOOL EDUCATOR
FOR ALMOST FIFTY YEARS AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX FOURTEEN.
THANK YOU AND I HAVE NO FURTHER
LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO ALL
THOSE WHO PARTICIPATED ARE
HEARING THUS FAR WE
APPRECIATED- AND SO QUICKLY
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ALL JUST. KIND IT
SPEAK TO KIND OF HELP THIS IS
GONNA OF IN A LOT OF PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS IN THE
FIRST VERSION OF THIS BILL I
RECOGNIZE WORK AS IT IS HAD
GETTING RID OF THE RICA PERIOD
RIGHT. AND. THE MORE THE
PROMISE OF GETTING RATHER
BECAUSE WELL SOME PEOPLE CAN'T
PASS IT WHAT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR
ME BECAUSE WE TO THINK OF KIDS
ARE. BUT WHAT YOU REALLY WANT
TO. HERE IS YOU TO GO A PAPER
TESTS TO A PERFORMANCE TEST.
YOU KNOW YOU YOU CAN. GET OF
TEACH SOMEONE TO SHOW SOMEONE
HOW TO BUILD A HOUSE AND THEN
GET MY TEST ON IT OR YOU CAN
TEACH SOMEONE SHOW SOMEONE HOW
TO BUILD A HOUSE AND JUNGLE
BUILD A HOUSE. RIGHT YOU'RE
GONNA KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THEY
CAN DO IT. OKAY ONCE THEY'VE
TRIED TO BUILD A HOUSE MORE
THAN. YOU KNOW HOW THEY'VE
ANSWERED ON PAPER TESTED TO ME.
THIS MAKES COMPLETELY SET
COMPLETE SENSE. I THINK IT'S
THOUGHT THROUGH. I KNOW NOT
EVERYBODY WAS IN LOVE WITH MY
POSITION ON THIS BUT I CAN TAKE
IT BECAUSE I DO THINK.
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS. SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TEACH READING IT SHOULD
BE A SPECIFIC SKILL SET. AND
THEY SHOULD BE TESTED SOMEHOW
THAT SKILL SET JUST PUTTING IN.
HANDING SOMEONE A PIECE OF
PAPER TO HEY TAKE A TEST AND
HOW HA HA HA. AND HOW WE
READING ISN'T GOOD ENOUGH BIG
BECAUSE- KIDS ARE HUMANS AND
WITH KIDS COME ALL KINDS OF
VARIABLES. AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT HAVING BEEN A
CLASSROOM TEACHER FOR MANY
YEARS. SO AGAIN- I APPRECIATE
YOUR TENACITY SAYING THIS BILL.
IN WHETHER AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE PLEDGE RELAX I
THINK IT IS A GOOD PLACE I
THINK IT'S A PLACE. SIR CAN.
CHILDREN BETTER. THAN THEY HAVE
BEEN IN THE PAST BY DISCOUNT.
MOST PAPER STE TESTOR MUCH. OF
THE. COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MR
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO I HAVE
ONE QUESTION BASED ON THE
OPPOSITION WE HEARD TO THAT I
RECEIVED IN MY OFFICE SEEMS TO
BE A CONSIDER AMOUNT OF CONCERN
THE DYSLEXIA COMMUNITY COULD
YOU SPEAK ABOUT WHAT THE
EFFORTS WILL BE GOING FORWARD
TO BE VERY INTENTIONAL ABOUT
THE INCLUSION OF THAT COMMUNITY
AS WE DECIDE WHAT THIS
PERFORMANCE EVALUATION LOOKS
LIKE AND HOW THEIR CONCERNS CAN
BE ADDRESSED. YES THANK YOU AND
CHAIR IF I MAY ASK WHAT BROUGHT
DEL TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION AND
THAT MEANT NO MORE
COMPREHENSIVE WAY THOUGHT OKAY
DON'T GET ON BOARD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN MEMBERS ARE
RIGHT ON THE START WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES- BUT WE READ THE
CHAIR I THIS RICA ISN'T GOOD
ENOUGH I JUST WANNA CORRECT- TO
MISCONCEPTIONS STATED BY THE
OPPOSITION. SO I'M NUMBER ONE
THAT. WE ARE NOT ELIMINATING
READING STANDARDS- THE AT
CALIFORNIA'S ADOPTED. A
LITERACY FREE MARKET AND
STANDARDS ENCOMPASSES THE
SCIENCE BASED MULTIMODAL
READING INSTRUCTION DESCRIBED
BY THE OPPOSITION. ON END AND
ARE A TEACHER PERFORMANCE
EXPECTATIONS ON FROM LITERACY
RECENTLY- UPDATED AND ADOPTED
BY THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. INCORPORATE
CALIFORNIA'S DYSLEXIA. LINES
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN. SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS JUST AS THE CHAIR
DESCRIBED TAKING A PAPER AND
PENCIL TEST AND MAKE IT A-
TRULY PROVE TO US THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND HOW TO TEACH
READING. AND NOT JUST- ON THE
STANDARDS WE HAD IN NINETY FOUR
BUT I'M THOSE STANDARDS PLUS AN
UPDATE. PARTICULARLY FOR OUR
HIGHEST NEED STUDENTS THINKING
HERE AGAIN ABOUT. LIST LEARNERS
UNDERSTANDING THE NEEDS OF
DAHLE LANGUAGE LEARNERS AS WELL
AS STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
INCLUDING STUDENTS WITH
DYSLEXIA. AND ENTERED ME I I'M
SURE I'M SURE THAT I'M
SPEAKING. IN IN. WITH THE
CENTER THE- LOVES YOU I'M CALL.
CONNECT WITH WITH FOR EXAMPLE
SHE TO KIND OF A RECORD
STRAIGHT ON THE OTHER POINT I
MADE BY THE OPPOSITION. THERE'S
NOTHING NO KITCHEN. COUNTER AND
WE'RE WE'RE TAKING. UNTIL TESTS
AND ON. ONE AND- THE SAME AND
ADDITIONAL. INTO A PROVEN
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT BOTH OUR
ASSESSMENTS. THAT ARE AT THE
STATE WHICH ARE DAMAGED BY OUR
STATE BY A COMMISSION HE-
COULDN'T WHICH- HAVE CHIU. WITH.
THE HIGH STANDARDS FOR TWO AND-
THANK YOU MUCH FOR THE EFFORT.
TO GO BACK AND WANTED JUST
WANNA REITERATE WE ARE IN THE
FOR TEACHER TO TEACH AND
INCREASE THE PROP THAT THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY ABLE TO BE
EFFECTIVE TEACHERS DAY ONE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE PROVEN AND
PERFORMANCE INSTEAD OF JUST ON
A PAPER AND PENCIL TEST THANK
YOU. AND IF I MAY ADD WAS IT
WAS THE POSIT POSITION OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
TOO PRESCRIPTIVE IN THE BILL
BECAUSE WE MEANING MAY AND MANY
OTHERS IN THIS ROOM ART BUT
YOUR EXPERTS AND HOW TO TEACH
READING YES I'VE TAUGHT READING
I DON'T KNOW THAT I CONSIDER
MYSELF AN ABSOLUTE EXPERT AND-
SO WHAT WE'RE SEEKING IS HAND
THIS OVER THE CTC. THEM WHAT
CONSOLE THE EXPERTS ALSO TAKE
STAKEHOLDER INPUT SO THOSE
FOLKS WHO SPOKEN TODAY THAN MEN
THAT FROM THE DYSLEXIC
COMMUNITY AND BEYOND WHO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS APPROACH-
THEY'RE NOT LEFT OUT THERE NOT
WRITTEN INTO THE BILL BECAUSE
NO ONE'S SPECIFICALLY. NO NO NO
NO SPECIFIC CHALLENGES WRITTEN
INTO THE BILL BUT AS THE NEW
PERFORMANCE TESTED CREATED BY
THE CDC THOSE FOLKS SHOULD BE
OUT ROUTINE IS. THAT DEMANDING
TO BE ALLOWED AND SO THAT THAT
THEY CAN IT THIS IS A PROCESS
IT'S JUST THE BILL'S GONE AND
THAT'S IT WHERE OVER TO THE-
TEACHING ANGELA. CAN TO DEVELOP
THIS TO AGAIN A AS OUR EX. THAT
THEY WILL TAKE. STAKEHOLDER
INPUT AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT
THEY WILL AS MANY TIMES. AS AS
THEY USUALLY DO WHEN THEY- GO
AND TAKE ON ENDEAVOR SUCH AS
THIS. THE QUESTION IS HOW MUCH
OF WHAT THE AT THANK YOU BUT I
PLEAD OF. IT WAS A CLOSE FRIEND
HI CAN I DON'T DID YOU HAVE
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO ADD NOT
THAT I LIKE A CLOSE BUT I.
DON'T. GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER
RUBIO SO I AND AS I UNDERSTAND
THIS BILL WELL AS AMENDED THE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN PLACE TO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AT. AND THIS
IS A GUT AND AMEND WE'RE
DEALING WITH THIS DIDN'T START
OF THE SENATOR WAS SOMEONE ELSE
UNTIL RECENTLY. CAN I CLARIFY
AT THIS BILL AND I JUST WANNA
ADDRESS THE POINT THAT A
GENTLEMAN MADE THAT WE SHOULD
BE RUSHING THIS FOR THE-PANDEMIC SO I WANT TO MAKE VERY
CLEAR THAT THIS BILL. STARTED
LAST YEAR AND A BASED ON THE
OPPOSITION'S RECOMMENDATION
THEY ASKED ME TO PULL IT
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT LAST YEAR
WAS TOO SOON AND I DID. AND SO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING AN ENTIRE
YEAR WITH OUR A LOT OF TAKE.
AND KIND ME MY MEETING TO COME
UP WITH. THAT EVERYONE CAN GET
ON BOARD WITH AND I THINK
THERE'S A MISCONCEPTION WHEN
PEOPLE READ THE BILL BECAUSE I
HEARD THAT WE'VE DWINDLE DOWN
BE EXPECTATIONS TO ONE
PARAGRAPH. THIS IS JUST THE
BILL THAT'S GOING TO DIRECT YOU
KNOW THE CITY IF YOU TO COME UP
WITH A MORE COMPREHENSIVE-
STANDARDS BUT I DID MEET WITH
SOME AT THE OPPOSITION THE
DYSLEXIA COMMUNITY AND I
OFFERED THAT WE WOULD. TRY TO
ENGAGE THEM SO THEY CAN HAVE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE AS WELL SO I
FOUGHT FOR THAT ALREADY. WELL
THAT'S GREAT TO HEAR BUT I MEAN
WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THE- SAYS
WOULD. LEAD MORE THOROUGH. IF
FIVE. THE BILL HAS THE BENEFIT
OF THE POOL LEGISLATIVE. WERE
IT STARTS YOUR HOUSE RATHER
THAN. GUTTING AMENDING. A FEW
WEEKS BEFORE WE ADJOURN. I CAN
I WILL JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE RIGHT BUT IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE THE STARTED
LAST YEAR AND THAT'S WHY I
PULLED IT BECAUSE- AGAIN TO
GIVE IT UP A LITTLE BIT MORE
REVIEW AND- MORE. FROM OUR
STAKEHOLDERS SO IT'S NOT
SEVENTY NOW WE JUST CAME UP
WITH. A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK IT
CAME DURING THE PANDEMIC THIS
HAS BEEN WORKED ON SINCE LAST
YEAR THAT'S NOT REALLY ECHO THE
BILL RIGHT. I'M SORRY IT'S NOT
REALLY A CODE RELATED BILL WELL
IT IS AND I'LL SHOW YOU A WHITE
BECAUSE OUT THE GOVERNOR JUST
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
ALLOWS THE READER TO BE
POSTPONED FOR A PERIOD OF FIVE
YEARS SO RIGHT NOW THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE TO TAKE IT. AND SO
THIS ALLOWS THE TIME DURING THE
INTERCOM TO WORK ON SOMETHING
THAT'S EFFECTIVE. ESSAY THIS I
GUESS WHY NOT JUST- YOU KNOW IT
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE THAT WINDOW
WHETHER IT'S FIVE YEARS WHETHER
IT TOLD TWENTY FOUR. OH WHAT
NOT YOU KNOW INTRODUCED ON MY
THIS IN JANUARY WE CAN GO
THROUGH A FULL. PROCESS
HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE FOLKS IN
THE ROOM TO TESTIFY AND YOU
KNOW IN WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
A BILL THAT'S EVOKED AS
POWERFUL OPPOSITION FROM
DYSLEXIA TICKETS FROM. RIGHTS
GROUPS ON OUTLOOK THE EXPERTS
FROM AT ASC FROM. FROM STUDENTS.
IN IS TOUCHING UP ITEM
IMPORTANT ISSUES. WHY DON'T WE
JUST THAT WE'RE TO YOU KNOW.
DEAL THIS ISSUE. NEXT WE CAN IN.
FOR DID FOR. YOU OUT THOSE AND
SEE THE BEST THIS IS UP AND IN
YOUR ADDRESS THAN HAVE THIS
RUSH. SISTER. VERY YOU KNOW
CAREFULLY- YOU KNOW BOB FINDING
GAUGING IN THE PROCESS SO IT'S
NOT LIKE ANY OTHER BILL THAT WE
RUSHED TO THE SESSION. THIS IS
BEEN A YEAR LONG PROCESS AND AS
MUCH AS WE HAVE. OPPOSITION WE
ALSO HAVE SUPPORT AND I AGAIN.
I WILL DEFINITELY ENCOURAGE
THEM TO JOIN US IN THE PROCESS.
NOW THE MORE WE WAIT THE MORE
WE RUN. THE ABLE TO. AFFORD MY
AND I FEEL THAT THE MORE. THAT
THE SOONER WE GET GOING IN THE
MORE WE CAN THAT. HAVE
OVERSIGHT HAVING AGE MEN
PARTICIPATION TO MEET THE MORE.
THE SOONER WE START THE MORE ON
EFFECTIVE PROP PRODUCT WE WILL
HAVE. YEAH I UNDERSTAND THAT
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'VE WORKED
HARD TO GET AS MUCH INPUT AS
POSSIBLE AND THE BILL HAS
EVOLVED BUT- YEAH EVERYTHING
YOU JUST MENTIONED THAT
HAPPENED OUTSIDE OF PUBLIC VIEW
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO. ACTUAL
BILL THAT WAS MOVING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AND SO
I YOU KNOW WOULDN'T WE BE
BETTER POSITION HAVING DONE ALL
OF THAT WORK THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY DONE. TO THEN TAKE THAT
AND HAVE A PUBLIC PROCESS NEXT
YEAR. FOR SOMEONE THAT'S NOT
GOING TO TAKE A FACT FOR A FEW
YEARS AND SO THERE'S NO SENSE
OF URGENCY TO IT. WELL I'M
AGAIN I YOU KNOW I RESPECT YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS BUT I DO FEEL
THIS IS A PUBLIC PROCESS YOU'VE
HEARD ALL THE- PEOPLE. THAT
ENGAGED IN A CONVERSATION I'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN TO SO MANY HOURS.
ZOOM WITH A LOT OF THE DYSLEXIC
COMMUNITY TRYING TO ANSWER
THEIR QUESTIONS EDUCATE I'M SO
IT WASN'T SOMETHING THAT I
DIDN'T ENGAGED IN. THEY CANNOT
TEST ALL THE HOURS I SPEND WITH
SO MANY DIFFERENT GROUPS CELL.
I FELT THAT I DONE MY DUE
DILIGENCE IN TRYING TO- NOT
ONLY YOU KNOW A CAR FIVE SOME.
CONCEPTIONS BUT ALSO GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A TAPE. KIM
THANK. THANK YOU THEIR COMMENTS
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM ANY OF
THE COMMUNITY YES DOCTOR. I
WANT TO THANK THANK YOU FOR THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT YOU PUT
INTO THIS AND FORTUNATELY HE
CALLED ME TODAY AND I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU. IN A AND
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE GET TO THE
FLOOR BECAUSE I DO WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD AND SEE WHAT EVERYBODY
THINKS ABOUT IT. MAINLY
BECAUSE- I DON'T THINK YOU KNOW
I FEEL VERY STRONGLY THAT THE
CURRENT WHATEVER WE'RE DOING IS
NOT WORKING. AT ALL THAT WE
HAVE NOT MASTERED THE IDEA OF
TEACHING CHILDREN TO READ. AND
THAT IS THAT FUNDAMENTAL THING
I MEAN IT DOESN'T SEEM MOST
EVERYBODY HERE LEARN TO READ
AND SO YOU WONDER. WHAT IS THE
PROBLEM HAVEN'T WE MASTERED IT.
AND OTHER STATES HAVE. TRIED
DIFFERENT THINGS AND THEY HAVE
A LOT OF. HANDS ON ASSESSMENT
AND MENTORING AND ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT WE TALK ABOUT BUT
WE NEVER GET AROUND TO DOING.
AND WE HAVE OVER THE YEARS TAKE
A SHORT CUT OF GIVING PEOPLE A
TEST. THING IF THEY HAVE THE
KNOWLEDGE. AND I'VE RUN ACROSS
SOME EXTREMELY IT. UP
INTELLIGENT. EDUCATORS WHO ARE
TOTALLY INEFFECTIVE WHEN IT
COMES TO TEACHING KIDS. THEY
COULDN'T THEY HAVE MEMORIZED
EVERYTHING THERE IS THEY KNOW
ALL THE BOOKS IN THE ALL THE
THEORIES AND WHAT HAVE YOU. BUT
THE WHOLE IDEA OF HAVING A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE STUDENTS.
AND FIGURING OUT THE THINGS
THAT CAUSES DOOMED TO HAVE
BARRIERS IN CERTAIN AREAS WITH
THIS AFTER. OUR PARTY OR
READING OR WHATEVER AS THEY
JUST BEAR. SO AND THE DIFFERENT
CAN SEE BETWEEN THE PERFORMANCE
OF KIDS WHO CAN READ IN THOSE
WHO CAN'T IT IS. AMAZING AND
MEET. AT EVERY. I FEEL FRESH.
AS YOU KNOW OF. THANK YOU FOR
FIVE YEARS ALL WHO CAN READ I
MEAN WE COULD LITERALLY READ
AND THEN THE A COP EVER UP SOME
WHAT THE HECK GOING ON YOU KNOW
AND SO THIS IS SUCH A ISSUE AND
SO I KNEW I WAS NO WE CAN'T DO
GET RID OF IN THAT STUFF IN
PLACE. WHICH IS GIVEN SOME
DIRECTION AND FIVE THAT'S A
THAT YOU THAT YOU NEED TO SET
IN THIS IS THAT WE GET RID OF
IT NOW ONE OF TO COME WILL OKAY
LOW PUT THIS PLACE AND I'VE HAD
FOR WITH THIS ELIMINATING CBS
NOT THAT I'VE BEEN THE BEST
CELL MATE BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE AND SO SOMETIMES
WE MADE IT AND LAW IS THE COLD
AS AN- WELL YOU KNOW WE DON'T
HAVE TIME DO THIS AND THAT. AND
OUR KIDS ARE- AND AS A RESULT
OF THAT WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A HUGE
NUMBER TEACHERS TO DROP ON AND
IT'S A SHORTAGE AND SO OUT
WHICH CHANGE KIDS BUS YEAH
PROBLEM WE HAVE A KIND AND IS
NOT A- THAT THANK GOODNESS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT SOME OF THE
UP OF HIS ABOUT. HIS PEOPLE TO
ADVANTAGE WHICH WHEN YOU GET
AND SO THEREFORE YOU JUST
EIGHTY ALL REQUIRED WHICH TO ME
IS A IS A RECIPE VAST BECAUSE I
CAN DESTROY WHAT DOES THIS
LEARNING STUFF THAT'S GONNA.
AND IT'S A WHOLE HORDE OF KIDS
WOULD NOT BEEN AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS HAVE TO. DO THE
FIRST. TO THAT PROCESS. WE
TALKED. IT AND I AND I DON'T
HAVE A MUCH. FAITH IS PEOPLE
HAVE. IT THE SYSTEM WORKING.
OKAY THAT IT'S GONNA WERE.
BETTER DID THE- CREDENTIALING
PEOPLE GOING TO DO THEIR JOB.
WHAT I'VE ASKED HER TO DO IS
TO. DO MORE THAN WAIT FOR FOUR
YEARS. FOR THE LEGISLATURE. BUT
TO HAVE THESE PEOPLE COME BACK
TO US AND REPORT TO US WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. YEAH SO DO WE
GET A SENSE OF IT AND THAT
GIVES US FOR YEARS OR THREE
YEARS TO SAVE. YOU A BILL NOT
THAT WE WILL KEEP RECALL IF YOU
CAN REPEAL IT AND MOVE ON. BUT
WE HAVE TO START THE PROCESS
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO HAVE THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE LEGISLATURE.
BECAUSE IF WE JUST WAIT WE JUST
SAY IS TO BE DONE AND FOR YEARS
I'VE SEEN. WHAT SOMETIMES
HAPPENS CVE PEOPLE GET ALL
WHILE THEY TAKE THE THING THIS-PRIORITY FIRST. AND I'VE HAD
SEVERAL TIMES THEY CALLED ME
AND SAID WELL WE CAN IMPLEMENT
YOUR BILL THIS YEAR WE HAVE TO
WAIT TO MAKE FEAR. BECAUSE WE
HAVE A BUTTON THAT MONEY WOULD
HAVE WHATEVER. AND I DON'T WANT
THIS TO FALL OFF THE OFF THE
CLIP. IS FOR. IT FOR YOU MOST
BEFORE. THE KIND SEVEN. THE
SOME OF NOT EVEN BE HERE FOUR
YEARS OLD. IT HAS TO BE
SOMETHING THAT THAT THEY COME
BACK TO. WITH US ON A REGULAR
BASIS AND I'VE ASKED HER TO
MEND BE ABLE. TO BASICALLY DO
THAT IT HAS SOME ACCOUNTABILITY
AND IT NOW THEY SAID THEY COME
BACK IN FOUR YEARS BUT- BY. WE
DON'T. WANT TO AND YOU WON'T
HAVE A COPY. OF IN. THIS SINCE
OUR- THINK IT IS. ARE WE RUSHED
OF THINGS IN THE WE'VE LIMB
THING ALL THE WITH THINKING
WHAT COMES PLACE THIS IS SO I'M
BECAUSE WE WE'RE DOING. IS NOT
WORKING PERIOD IF YOU BEING
ABLE TO A TEST AND SAY YOU CAN
MASS THE SKILL IT IS NOT
WORKING AND WE SEE THAT NOT
ONLY THIS BUT ALMOST EVERYTHING
ELSE WE HAVE TO HAVE VERY
STRONG MENTORING PROGRAMS TO
CREATE GREAT TEACHERS AT OUR
SYSTEM WILL NOT IMPROVE. WILL
NOT IMPROVE WITHOUT THREE
TEACHERS PERIOD IT'S NOT I
DON'T CARE HOW MANY COMPUTERS
WITH THAT I MEAN YOU HAVE KIDS
WHO IN TURN ON THESE COMPUTERS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE SCHOOL
PERIOD THEY'VE NOT DONE WELL IN
IT TURN IT ON IS NOT WILL MAKE
THEM ANY BETTER IN THEIR MIND
AND SOUL WE YOU CAN'T BUY LOVE
AKE NOT. TO SCHOOL WITH AND
NOT UP BUILDING A BILL TO
IMPROVE OUR SCHOOLS IT'S NOT
THAT DOUBLES THE BUT WE KNOW
THAT THE RIVER IS LAG IN THE
RELAY BETWEEN THE THAT INTENT
THE AND STUDENT. THE TRYING A-
HAPPENS TO PAY AND TO
PARTICIPATE LIKE QUITE IN
SCHOOL BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TO DETERMINE THE KIDS READ AND
THEY ALL THAT CAN WE YEAH THEY
HAVE NO COMPREHENSION THE
COLUMN. SO ALL THE REAL
WRESTLING THAT CONTENT THAT AND
THAT'S DELAY AT THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY THE WORK
YOU GOTTA THAT'S- TO MAKE IT SO
I'M GOING TO BUT IT'S- MAYBE.
AT AND I. POURED OUT WE-
WAITING IN LATE AND WHAT. AND
DOING THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AND THINKING GET DE
RESULTS. TEST TEST TEST THESE
PEOPLE BE TEACHER WE SAY THAT
FOR. AND THEY'RE STILL EFFECT
OF IN THE CLASS. AND IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THEY THEY MAY MASKED
THE FEAR. BUT THEY HAVE NOT
ABLE INPUT IT AND PRACTICE AND
THAT'S WHAT REALLY MATTERS SO.
I THANK YOU I KNOW YOU'VE DONE
A LOT OF WORK I KNOW WOULD WE
WILL HERE LAST YEAR AND SALAS.
SINCE THEN YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
ALL THESE GROUPS. AND I THINK
THAT THIS LEXUS COMMUNITY IS
NERVOUS AND THEY SHOULD BE.
IT'LL ADD AND THEY SHOULD BE
GREATLY INVOLVED AND ENGAGED IN
WHAT'S TAKING PLACE. BUT FOR
EVERY OTHER MAN WHOSE KID IS
FAILING IN OUR DISTRICT SHOULD
BE GREATLY CONCERNED. AND
DEMANDING INPUT AND I'VE IN
SOME OF THE- FOLKS TESTIFYING
BECAUSE THEY NEED TO BE AT THE
TABLE. TO MAKE SURE THE WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS RIGHT. WE ALSO
HAVE TO BE THERE SO I'M HOPING
SHE WOULD DO THE AMENDMENTS.
PLEASE HAS THE. A REPORT. ALSO
THE CAN INSURE THAT WHAT PEOPLE
TELL US THAT TO DO IN IN IN THE
COULD DID FOR BUT THEY HAVE
BEGUN TO AND IF THEY HAVEN'T
THERE'S SOME FOR IN MONEY
WHATEVER WHATEVER WE SHOULD BE
THE LAW OF FIGHTING FOR THEM TO
GET THE THEY TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN BECAUSE READING IS FUN
EVERY KNOWS THAT AND OUR KIDS
NEED TO HAVE A GREAT READING
SKILLS IF THEY'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD OTHERWISE IT A LOT OF
THE STRUGGLE AND STRUGGLE YOUR
REST. YEAH YOU I SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY AS WELL I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING MISTER CHAIR THAT
WE HAVE SO MANY ISSUES AND
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE OF CODE IN THE- TRUNK
LET'S LIVE SESSION WERE
SPENDING. ALL THE TIME ON THIS
BILL. I THINK THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHER. ISSUES DEALING WITH. OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR READING AND-
DURATION OF OUR TEACHERS AND
THE EVEN OPPORTUNITY GAP. AND I
DO GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION AND THEIR CONCERNS
AS FAR AS READING SCORES IN
CALIFORNIA I KNOW YOU SAID THE
SAME THING BUT- I DON'T KNOW.
IF THESE TWO THINGS APART
CONFLATED IN AN APPROPRIATELY
IN OTHER WORDS- BY PUSHING THIS
BILL ARE WE SAYING ONE WE DON'T
CARE ABOUT THAT. AND TO IT'S
GOING TO WORSE AND- THAT SHE
MET FOR READING CALIFORNIA I
DON'T I DON'T SEE THAT THAT'S
THE CASE AND- I DO THINK THAT
THIS HAS A LARGER ISSUE WERE
THEY WERE TRYING TO. ADDRESS
AND THAT. TEACHING THAT CAST WE
KNOW FROM ALL KINDS OF THINGS
DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK. THANK YOU
SAID YOUR EXPERIENCE AND HONEST
O'DONNELL TALKED ABOUT YOUR
EXPERIENCE IN THE CLASSROOM AS
WELL. AND I DO THINK THAT WE
NEED TO BROADEN THE BASE WHO'S
A TEACHER IN CALIFORNIA I'D I
THINK THAT- THIS CAN ONLY HELP
NOT THE PANACEA THEY'RE ALL
KINDS OF OTHER ISSUES WERE
LOOKING. TO ADDRESS- BUT- I AND
I APPRECIATE LEARNING ABOUT
THIS AN AGING PARENT. I THINK
THE YEAR WORKING TO MAKE IT
BETTER AND I APPRECIATE. YOUR
EFFORTS AND WITH THAT I WILL.
SUPPORT THE BILL MAKE THE
MOTION SUPPORT RIGHT NOW SO I
CAN CAN. START YEAH. SAY NO
FURTHER CONTACT MOTION IS TO
MODIFY VEHICLES IT JUST REALLY
QUICK I FIRST OF ALL I THINK
THE DOCTOR WEBER IDEA COMMIT
TECH THAT DAY AND WE BOTH
ABILITY IS REALLY IMPORTANT
PIECE FOR ME AS WELL AND I
APPRECIATED HER SUGGESTION
ABOUT YOU KNOW WORKING ON
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW ALLOWS
THEM TO UPDATE THIS YEAR HE
VERSUS YOU KNOW FOR YEARS BUT I
REALLY WANT TO TAKE THE TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THE PARENTS
THAT IT ON THE TEACHER. THE
EDUCATE COMMUNITY IN FACT I'M
STOOD. ON AND SO UNDER. FIRST
SOME THE KIND. AND ABSOLUTELY
VALLEY I WOULD BE CONCERNED IF
I HAD A CHILD BUT I WANTED TO
JUST REITERATE THAT OUR GOAL IS
TO MAKE IT BETTER AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT. AS A TEACHER I
CAN SAY FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS IS.
IT'S THE LACK OF CLASSROOM
EXPERIENCE I'VE SEEN TEACHERS.
YOU KNOW BUT YOU KNOW GET A
REALLY HIGH SCORES IN THEIR
COLLEGE AND THEY PASSED THE RE
GOT A COMMENT AND WITHIN MONTHS
THEY QUIT THE PROFESSION
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T HANDLE THE
CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE. THIS
WILL. DEFINITELY BE I'M IT
THERE IN THE SENSE THAT THE
TEACHERS WILL HAVE THAT
CLASSROOM IT IT'S- AS EACH OF
THE NON OPERATED. ARE HERE COME
PLANNED THE PERFECT LESSON
PLAN. BUT EVERY CLASS IS
DIFFERENT YOU GET TO THE
CLASSROOM AND IT'S NOT A
PERFECT LAST. HAVE TO DEAL. YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT. CHALLENGES FOR
DIFFERENT KIDS AND TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF REAL
LIFE CHILDREN FIRST. TASK SO I
AM COMMITTED TO. EVERYTHING
THAT I'VE SAID HERE ARE YOU
KNOW MORE UPDATE. AND
DEFINITELY IN TIMOR STEAK FOR.
WITHOUT I READ. PASS FOR APPLE
YEAH THANK. MOTION THE MAN FOR
PREPARATION ORDER HI THE DOW I
KIND. HIGHLY NO DE NO DALY CALL.
ALRIGHT I MCCARTY RIGHT PARTY
ICE FIVE SMITH I WEBER FIVE
WEBER I THE- FIVE THE BILL HAS
FIVE OH TODAY'S. THANK YOU WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE
ROLE OF. THIS MCCARTY TO. ADD
ON I DON'T KNOW OF ANYONE ELSE
DOES. YEAH. I WANT THREE YEAH
OKAY GOOD I'M THE CONSENT FILE
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE. CAN.
OKAY YEAH YEAH WE'RE GOOD FOR.